entre la oscuridad y el frío se
encuentran los habitantes de gersón tras
los ataques rusos sobre la
infraestructura eléctrica
aquí tiene lugar una grosera violación
del derecho internacional humanitario
lo más probable es que se trate de un
crimen de guerra con una alta
posibilidad se puede hablar de ataques
indiscriminados a infraestructuras
civiles a bloques de apartamentos
anoche nos desconectaron el gas el agua
y la electricidad de todo nuestras
puertas también fueron perforadas
según las autoridades un bombardeo
desconectó el suministro de la recién
restaurada electricidad muchos de los
residentes huyen de esta ciudad
ucraniana que hasta hace tres semanas
estuvo bajo dominio ruso
queremos irnos aquí ahora porque aquí da
mucho miedo iremos aquí y luego
aternopill allí esperaremos esperamos
volver pronto a casa
Así mismo ludmila velocista de 79 años
decidió abandonar gerson y unirse a sus
hijos en kiev por el temor a que la
situación empeore además recordó que
nació y vive aún en guerra
el ataque fue tan masivo que nuestra
casa incluso empezó a temblar por eso
Tenemos que irnos esos bombardeos me dan
mucho miedo fui una niña de la guerra y
ahora soy una abuelita de la guerra
Ucrania aún no levanta cabeza tras los
constantes ataques rusos con drones y
artillería pesada sobre sus ciudades
siendo gersón la más fuertemente
afectada según la oficina presidencial
de Ucrania al menos dos civiles murieron
y otros seis resultaron heridos en todo
el país por los últimos bombardeos rusos